thank I'm at Duane Reade and I'm working
for the wax but I don't know what I'll
do axes in it's not with the makeup it's
not with the soap it's with the hair
brushes Hank I am about to wax my chin
what should I expect from this pain
first we have to microwave the wax
Gautam Gautam Gautam Gautam did it I do
now I have to go wash my face I'm really
worried you've made it out to be so
horrible the time has come Hank
the wax is about to be applied
one I'm very scared
one two three Oh God oh my god
how did I come off I pulled so hard
one two three Oh oh my god one can I
pull slowly Oh bleeding bleeding that's
suck because I'm a hard worker and I
believe in the project and I believe in
Brotherhood 2.0 I'm gonna try it one
more time but if I bleed again that's it
Oh God
it's much harder to do once you know how
much it's gonna suck I mean last time I
was like oh ah this time I know how much
it's gonna hurt one oh god I don't want
to do it oh my god
one two three Oh see all the blood you
bastard Hank we're going to have to
switch punishments because this one
makes me bleed ninety four percent fat
free popcorn only two points on Weight
Watchers for the entire bag mint
chocolate chip ice cream
13 points I'm going to watch the mint
chocolate chip milk while I eat my
crappy popcorn
thanks for giving me an alternative
punishment I'll see you tomorrow